if a guy deals drugs when he goes to
jail when he's younger okay when he
talks to the younger men he'll say stay
away you you you literally can see like
interviews in prison of men talking
about this they'll say hey young guys do
not go down that path you don't have to
do that but older women will justify
doing it for younger women older men
will say hey that's a bad path don't go
down they won't justify and say no you
have to sell drugs you have to commit
crimes no they'll give the men the right
information now some men will take that
advice and some won't they can't really
help who does but at least they have the
correct information